that's where we begin tonight the very
terrible story about the death of Kate
Spade the sister of the celebrated
fashion designer says that she may have
taken her own life because of a struggle
with mental illness Spade was found dead
yesterday in her New York apartment by
her housekeeper her sister said in an
email to CBS this morning that she
believed that Spade suffered from
bipolar disorder she wrote this it
finally took her took its toll on her a
very tragic and sad ending to the life
of a very colorful and delightful being
Kate Spade's aspirational but affordable
designs influenced popular culture vogue
editor-in-chief Anna Wintour said there
was a moment when you couldn't walk a
block in New York without seeing one of
her bags which were just like her
colorful and unpretentious and UN
Ambassador nikki Haley said spades death
is a stark reminder that we never know
the struggles of a person regardless of
their outward persona
Jericka Duncan is outside a Kate Spade
store in New York Jericka good morning
good morning the motto for Spade fashion
line is live colorfully but beneath the
glamorous exterior police tell CBS this
morning that Spade was wrestling with
financial and family issues police say a
housekeeper found Kate Spade hanging
from a red scarf tied to a doorknob in
her bedroom her husband Andy was home at
the time the designer left a suicide
note addressed to her 13 year old
daughter telling her it was not her
fault the contents of that note as well
as the physical state of the apartment
and the comments of the witness led to
the credibility that it is an apparent
suicide her family said in a statement
we are all devastated and we loved Kate
dearly and we'll miss her terribly
spades older sister Rita Sappho suspects
the designer may have suffered from
bipolar disorder
Sappho tells CBS this morning she tried
numerous times to get her help
I think women do want something that's
interesting the 55 year old became a
fashion industry darling in the 90s with
a simple but whimsical style some color
some textures and prints I don't know I
something a little more interesting but
also elegant she and her husband Andy
built a fashion empire around her
signature handbags counting celebrities
like Ellie Kemper among her clientele
she puts forth a sort of aspirational
line which I think oh I want to be like
that I want to be chic and pulled
together and a New York lady and then I
can spade stepped away from the
limelight after selling her company in
2007 but she recently mounted a comeback
I personally I love that Andy took off a
good 90 years raising my daughter and
absolutely adored every moment of it
police say she may have taken her own
life because of money and marital
problems she and Andy Weber team I mean
they were adorable together
New York Fashion Week creator fern
Mallis who news paid for nearly three
decades says she was shocked by her
death I just want what the last person
on earth you would think will take her
life
Spade's brother-in-law actor David Spade
tweeted out this picture that said at
his book signing that I love this pic of
her so pretty it's a rough world out
there people now obviously Kate Spade's
death has brought a lot of attention to
mental health and awareness if you do
need help you can go to the national
suicide prevention hotline it's one
eight hundred two seven three eight two
five five Nora
alright tarika thank you you know the
reaction to this yes is a reminder that
suicide rates are going up and I looked
into the number of suicides no twice
that of homicides I saw a lot of women
online saying the best thing I ever did
was get treated for depression and
anxiety it probably saved my life so
there is another secondary conversation
going on as well as the shock of what
happened about how to get treatment and
it's so important I keep thinking about
her little daughter you know I met Kay I
can't say I know Kate Spade about I met
her several times and she was always so
bright and so sparkly and it just shows
you that you never really know what's
going on and I'm hoping that in some way
is horrible that this is that it will
nor open the conversation for people to
say you can and you should get help I
keep thinking the despair she must have
felt that she had to think that this was
the only option that I had is so
upsetting to and also those of us who
are friends with people we think might
be trying to keep a brave face how we
then approach them in other words it's
not the person who's hurting that needs
to reach out but we need to find a way
in well said well said